each week when you join us here on CBS
Saturday morning you get to know a
little bit about us simply by seeing our
interactions well now Michelle is
sharing even more in her new Memoir
belonging A daughter's search for
identity through loss and love she takes
us through her journey to connect to the
mother that she never knew and the two
of us got together recently to talk
about it that meant I got to put
Michelle in unfamiliar territory
answering questions instead of asking
them
all this for Michelle Miller
I know that's what the table's being
turned I can't believe we're like here
after three decades in TV broadcasting
Michelle Miller has developed a talent
for telling stories I have never shied
away from telling the stories of my
people
or other people
cast
in a forgotten life who don't have the
voice that you do and you get to raise
their voice I love telling those stories
but when it came to sharing her own
Michelle needed to be convinced he knows
it's like little old me what would
anybody want to read my story about in
2020 she gave viewers a glimpse of the
answer in a personal essay reacting to
the murder of George Floyd I was raised
in South Central Los Angeles the product
of an interracial Union that my father
celebrated and my mother to this day
does not acknowledge the peace caught
the attention of Publishers from
harpercollins who encouraged her to
write a book something long time CBS
colleague Anthony Mason had been telling
her to do for some time he said the
opening line is
I am my mother's Secret
and I remember like thinking whoa
that is why I live out loud because for
so long in the back of my mind I've been
somebody's secret someone's kept me
small I'm unacknowledged it's like
finding that place of belonging is what
I always yearned for Michelle shares her
journey to find it in the aptly titled
belonging written with Rosemarie
robatham it begins in Los Angeles born
in 1967 the daughter of Ross Miller Jr a
prominent African-American surgeon who
as Michelle discovered in 2013 spoke to
CBS News after he tended to Robert
Kennedy the night he was assassinated in
1968. they were a massive blood and he
had head injuries the extent of them
could not be ascertained immediately her
mother is another story so my dad would
always describe my origin in the third
person okay your mother and your father
fell in love
and they had you
and your mother couldn't stay with us
so that's why we live with big mama
that's your dad's mom my dad's mother
the reality of it was that my father was
married to someone else
I presume it was a very unhappy marriage
based on a number of factors the
relationship between Ross and Michelle's
mother who she refers to as Laura
Hernandez in the book began at the
hospital where they both worked and
resulted in an unexpected pregnancy
Michelle writes she went into labor
early one morning and pushed me into the
world that afternoon Laura discharged
herself from the maternity floor and
went home to her family she was Hispanic
she she presented white she never told
anyone on that side of her family this
photo of a one-year-old Michelle taken
in secret is the only one she has with
both her parents until she was six
months old family friends in Alabama had
cared for her from that point on her dad
would be a constant presence in her life
but she was raised by his mother
Beatrice Burson Miller Big Mama to
Michelle she was
72 73 years old
when she came out to get me she came out
and she's like that's my baby that's my
baby she's coming home with me this is
where I grew up on a quiet street in the
Vermont Knolls section of Los Angeles
better known as South Central I mean I
used to play football with my cousin
Tommy on this lawn and I just think
about my neighbors my neighbor would
play right about her yeah Lois the
tolsons the Ponders Mrs Hall Mr and Mrs
Holmes who used to take me to school
even after all these years there's at
least one neighbor still there Sterling
Jones a retired LAPD officer what do you
remember about Michelle as a kid do you
remember
this little young lady didn't take no
beer oh what happened Michelle what
happened I'm just kidding
as a child growing up here Michelle says
she struggled with her mixed race
identity and features most of the kids I
went to school with at that time were
brown skin
and I was here this light-skinned kind
of wavy-haired kid and I was like I just
looked at my skin and I said why
couldn't you just be one or the other
why do you have to be in between her
first sense of belonging came at Pacific
Palisades High School where she and
other kids of color were bust and after
graduation attending Howard University
she'd returned to Los Angeles to pursue
a career in TV journalism
during the riots following the acquittal
of the officers involved in the Rodney
King beating Michelle was working as a
reporter for the Orange County News
Channel and living at the epicenter she
recalled a moment of Hope amid the chaos
I was coming home from church and I
rounded the corner I see all of these
white cops chasing all these black boys
in the neighborhood and when I pulled up
I realized they were playing a game of
pickup basketball can you imagine like
that happening here on our block her
local news career would eventually take
Michelle to New Orleans all the best
students how you doing where she would
also meet the man she'd start her own
family with this is our wedding day
we're front page of the time
Michelle how on Earth did you date the
mayor there's a whole story this whole
chapter is about that there's my dad
that's so handsome yeah and then my
lovely children it might make Mason my
my boy not your baby anymore look at him
and then Margo she's the star Setter for
her volleyball team either one your
babies anymore no well they're always
your babies I guess they are
but it's a photo not on the wall the
decades spent searching for her mother's
acceptance that is the defining through
line of belonging at their first of
numerous clandestine meetings Michelle
writes her mother told her I can't
acknowledge you publicly as my daughter
that's just how it has to be I feel
sorry that she has been hiding all these
years
from
this
in the end it's through Michelle's
search for belonging that she hopes
Others May find theirs so many people
have a version of this story and in
particular so many people of color and
acceptance and belonging matter
they matter and people have got to get
with understanding that we belong to a
race of people human beings
we're a beautiful mixed diverse
incredible
human race
but like Get over hating somebody get
over feeling that you know folks can't
be accepting of one another for their
differences get over that
get over it and it just burns me up that
we don't
Michelle you show such vulnerability in
this book in the way you share your
story and I think one of the things that
stood out to me is what you did not have
as a child is what you've shared with so
many I want to put a picture up here
because there's one person we did not
get to show when we were looking at
these family photos or just one chemma
of course your stepdaughter you are a
mother to so many and this is your
family now you've mothered the way you
maybe weren't by a mother but so many
other women brought that to your life
beautiful Memoir it's out on Tuesday
beautiful beautiful job guys thank you
we'll be right back
welcome back sorry
there's so much to say what I was trying
to say is I'm sorry you had so many
women in your life and Michelle you have
you maybe did not have your birth mother
there but my god you're an incredible
mother to so many and in this book we
see so much about you and I do think
people can relate in so many different
ways to that story I I just let me get
over it is is what you know because I
think also it's something that other
people can look at who are not in the
exact same situation as you but someone
you talk about this and they can say I'm
not alone they aren't yeah they aren't
alone and if there's one reason why I
wrote this book uh folks asked me was it
therapy for you I don't know if it was
great therapy for me I'm sure it was I
still don't feel that but what I do know
is I wanted it to be a prim or a
template
a a moment for someone else to say just
what you did I'm not alone I am and I
shouldn't be discouraged by my origin
story or what has happened to me I'm
gonna live my life and I'm going to
create a life that I want
good for you yeah good for you for doing
this and thank I want you both to know
the books are yours and you have to sign
them but can I tell you this is a place
of belonging for me and I'm so grateful
to it everyone here knows I love our
space our place I love CBS News and I'm
so grateful for this family we have we
do but you also have created I think
maybe that's what I was trying to say
you've created a sense of belonging for
so many as well including here not for
Jeff we don't let him
belongs
your dish is next